damn Gucci Mane that's fine at this
point that's who I am uh I'm actually
shocked when somebody on the floor calls
me Jane nobody calls me James everybody
calls me Gucci
uh so I've really just embraced it well
I think again it makes it just it
humanizes us so uh referees who are just
the cops out there I'm not a big fan of
uh because that's not how I referee it's
like I go out there I like to have fun
uh Engage The Players the fans the
coaches while we have a job to do if
still have fun while you're doing it
once that thing went viral and I just
like my life has been completely altered
forever yes it is a part of who I am at
this point nobody calls me James this is
it's really quite comical to be honest
with you but
um even when I'm walking in the airport
the other day I was in O'Hare
and there was a basketball team walking
through I'm walking to my gate and
they're like that's the Gucci Mane ref
and we get a picture I think it's funny